hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
today I am extremely excited I feel like
every time I start out a video I'm
really excited because usually I'm
unboxing something cool and I get to
show you guys something amazing and
today that is no exception we are
unboxing the new Mavic platinum this
actually has a few new integrated
features that are different from the
original Mavic you can fly up to 30
minutes with the new intelligent flight
battery and it has 40% less noise so if
you thought the original matter Pro was
quiet then this thing is definitely way
more quiet than the previous and soon
we'll find out so some of you who may be
new here may not know but the Mavic
pearl has a very special place in my
heart and just think guys don't get it
confused this is the Mavic pearl
platinum the original one launched last
year and I got a chance to go to New
York we got the drone early we created a
really fun video to be a part of the
whole keynote event and it was so much
fun and I had the best time I got to go
in the stage I got to talk about how
drones have really changed my life
specifically with the Mavic because it's
so small its compact the quality is
incredible so basically you can take
this thing anywhere it's great because
when I was on stage I actually had my
purse with me and I was like I've got a
drone in my purse which usually would be
a joke but now it's a reality especially
with the spark now I'm getting off on a
tangent either way this is the new drone
that we're gonna be unboxing today the
mavet Pro platinum they also announced a
Mavic Pro Alpine it's beautiful it is
all white and it is absolutely fantastic
look it's unboxing gonna be heading up
to Big Bear so I will give you guys a
nice flight demo as soon as I get there
but right now I gotta unbox and get on
the road period is is a more platinum
color which is awesome hence the name
platinum hello baby here's our
controller pretty much the same as the
previous Mavic and the Platinum avek
right here my gosh this thing is awesome
if you guys haven't seen it already I
also did a really fun video on the DJI
goggles which these are also compatible
with so if you guys are a huge fan of
flying with the goggles and if you've
never experienced it it is definitely
something that I feel like if you don't
go and buy them yourself
find a friend rent them and try flying
in fpv
because it is just it's it really does
feel like you're flying but you're on
the ground and it really is so confusing
to your mind because you're like what is
happening right now in the latest math a
firmware update it will allow you to do
fixed-wing mode so if you're flying fpv
this will give you a much better
experience when you're flying with the
goggles there's also the new Kwik shop
function so if you guys are familiar
with a spark this was really great
because you could do a bunch of really
cool quick shops and it'll say it
directly to your phone you can save it
share it and it's pretty awesome let's
see what else we've got in here we have
got cut a power cable micro USB this is
what you connect your phone this this
looks pretty much identical to the
previous Mavic so if you do have an
older maverick you can also use that
charger yes they've got an extra set of
propellers which are also very important
it is always nice to keep these handy
just in case you break a blade because
if you do you can just pop these on and
you're ready to go but I like that these
have a new silver tip on them I need to
get myself to an Apple store and check
out the Alpine version because I bet it
looks so fresh take a look at this new
battery like I said this is the new
intelligent wolf-like battery much like
the phantom pro 4 if you're familiar
with that they also have a different
line of batteries that will allow you to
fly a little bit longer I'll tell you
what when you're on the air those extra
couple of minutes are very very crucial
you excited to see it it's not like I
haven't seen it right here yes yes yes I
didn't think the bottom was gonna look
this good I'm actually very surprised I
thought that it was gonna be like a
lighter gray color but I didn't realise
that it was gonna be so shiny just like
the other previous Mavic these little
guys have fold out is fold well as well
when you put this in sport mode let me
tell you what it is fast it looks really
really great I'm so excited I'm gonna go
grab my other maverick so I can give you
guys a side-by-side comparison here's
our platinum and here is our mammoth Pro
now these are both pro models but this
one definitely has some higher specs
like I said is the 40% quieter you get
the longer flight time I get to fly with
my new iPhone
which speaking of which look at this
nice look you guys look great together
this is clearly gonna work out very very
well what is this do you want the gold
tips they have two different colors this
is crazy
silver comes on them in the gold are the
extra ones that's kind of cool well I'm
gonna go charge this up set it up and
then I'm heading off to Big Bear and I
will do a flying demo and I'm looking
forward to seeing what you guys think
[Music]
there it is that's the Matic pro sounds
like
while we
now we're gonna climatic Pro platinum
we've got it right here so let's see
what this sounds like in comparison to
the pro just up in the air all right you
ready done
I'm really sure I can tell a difference
I mean is it 30% 40% 50% I'm not sure a
percentage but I think it sounds quieter
sounds like butter have you ever
listened to a stick of butter
[Music]
[Applause]
Pro platinum this thing is so amazing I
still have a sticker I don't even take
off because it was brand new
[Music]